welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
the same day that Avengers endgame
surpasses avatar to become the
highest-grossing movie of all time they
announced their universe shattering face
for lineup now unlike most of my videos
that are heavily scripted I'm just gonna
sort a freestyle this one and give my
reaction to the face for announcements I
haven't read all of them and I just kind
of want to go through each one and give
you my thoughts obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here about some of the
movies and things that were discussed at
the panels so if you don't want to know
anything about the films then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video I hope you
enjoy it now let's get into the phase
four breakdown okay so the panel started
with Kevin Feige revealing the infinity
Saga logo I'm sure many of you don't
really care about that so I'll skip past
it it is a nice logo but yeah nothing
earth-shattering there then they went on
to reveal the official logo for Marvel
Studios the Eternals movie and that's
gonna be confirmed to be released on the
6th of November 2020 the Eternals were a
group that I never really read that much
whenever I did it was always because
they featured in other people's comics
so my knowledge isn't that amazing on
them and it is getting a lot of hype
around this film now and I definitely
think that you know if they take the
right steps this could become another
huge blockbuster that sort of catapults
them from the D and the C list into the
a-list the main cast has been announced
and it's gonna be Lauren red laughs
Brian Terry Henry Richard Madden Lia
McHugh Don Lee Angelina Jolie and Kumail
Nanjiani how I pronounce that right a
lot of this has been rumored especially
the Richard Madden thing so it's great
to see that they lock this down they
have a clear vision they got who they
wanted and they're gonna steamroll the
head with it I definitely think it's
gonna be a great movie and I can't wait
to see what happens with it now next up
was an official logo for the Falcon and
Winter Soldier that's gonna be released
in the fall of 2020 on Disney Plus and
yet apparently Anthony Mackie right now
is getting fitted for his captain Tamara
a suit I'm very very excited about this
especially if the John Cena casting
rumors are true that's gonna have him as
a u.s. agent apparently the the plot is
gonna focus on them basically on the run
from the law and US agents trying to
track them down because he's basically a
government-appointed Captain America I
think it's gonna add a lot of diversity
to the Marvel Universe and yeah it's
gonna be a really thrilling show the
next announcement was shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings which is set to
release on February the 12th 2021 yeah
obviously the ten rings they kind of got
sidelined a bit in the Marvel Universe
so it's great to see that they're
bringing them back Octus emily has been
officially cast as shang-chi it's
obvious you know that they're they're
definitely aiming towards a Chinese
demographic on this especially with the
casting choices and this is sort of set
to take the bad taste out of your mouth
from Iron Man 3 in regards to the
Mandarin as actor Tony Luang has been
officially cast as the in bracket reel
Mandarin and we'll see how that goes
down it does feel like a bit of
retconning but I actually quite like
dying man 3 but we'll see if this is
more authentic Mandarin yeah but I'm
very excited for that as well
now the next announcement was the 1
division at Disney Plus TV series that's
been confirmed to take place after the
events of endgame which is interesting
as obviously vision was killed in
infinity war am so I do I do have my
theories on how they're gonna bring him
back but I'll I'll save you from them
for the moment and that's set to release
in spring 2021 on Disney Plus and the
follow up announcement was also a
massive Disney Plus advert which is Loki
and that's gonna be dropping spring 2021
they also give the logo for that and yet
obviously if you've seen Avengers
endgame you're very curious to know what
happened to Loki in that movie because
he got out of there really fast and
we're kind of left with an open-ended
thing of what could have happened to him
I think this is gonna be great it's
gonna be a massive seller for the Disney
Plus platform and obviously you know I'm
it's not getting released in the UK but
I'll find a way to watch it and give you
a full breakdown of it now the next line
up was Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness which is set to release on
May 7
20:21 this is gonna be a massive massive
movie I think for the MCU obviously the
multiverse is sort of being paid
lip-service to in spider-man far from
home but now that we have an official
film set around it it's really gonna
delve into all of the alternate
realities and I think it's massively
gonna open up the Marvel Universe to
different possibilities and different
ways of looking at things
Scarlet Witch is also set to appear in
that so hopefully that'll sort of build
on her role in one division and show
that these characters are really
something else
Lord Nightmare is also set to be the
villain and I've heard casting rumors
that they're looking for either
Christian Bale or Matt Smith but there
was no official announcement about who
who's gonna play that role but yeah if
they manage to get either one of those I
think it'll really work now after this
the Hawkeye Disney Plus series was
officially announced and that's set to
premiere in the fall of 2021 it's going
to start Jeremy Renner in the lead role
and it's also going to introduce Kate
Bishop to the MCU so this is massive
news for Marvel comic fans I've actually
seen this retreated quite a lot um it
seems like quite a big story so if
you're in in the comics then this is
just pure fanservice for you and yeah I
think it's really gonna work it's it's a
nice passing of the torch sort of thing
and I'm really looking forward to it and
again it's another reason to find a way
to watch Disney Plus shows then the next
announcement which in my opinion is the
biggest film from the phase four lineup
is Thor love and thunder that's gonna be
released on November 5th 2021 and it's
also going to have Valkyrie be reveal as
the first LGBTQ hero in the Marvel
Universe now this is big big news and
it's sort of strange that they've
announced door before guardians of the
galaxy as well as you know there's been
a lot of sort of back and forth behind
the scenes with James Gunn being fired
by Disney then going to work out Warner
Brothers to start work on the Suicide
Squad then being rehired by Disney and
that kind of delayed guardians of the
galaxy so I'm not sure exactly how
they're gonna pick up from the events of
Avengers endgame as obviously Thor and
that kind of went off with the Guardians
and I'm guessing they're gonna have to
change the script for guardians
galaxy 3 there's been no mention of beta
ray bill either and so yeah we'll see
how this goes obviously they're kind of
rushing the cell this was meant to be
after guardians of the galaxy 3 so we'll
see how it works and they'll obviously
have to adjust it to fit a new storyline
we also got confirmation that actress
and Natalie Portman will be returning as
Jane Foster and she will wield Manya as
the first female Thor in Thor love and
thunder which I went crazy for this news
this is absolutely outstanding I think
it's brilliant that they managed to get
her back and everyone was over the moon
to see her in Avengers and game even if
it was edited footage but yeah this is
gonna be something else and I'm really
excited for it now after this the Black
Widow movie was confirmed for May 1st
2020 with the official logo now being
revealed they hadn't actually confirmed
this and film even though we all knew it
was being made but yeah it's great to
see that they finally locked this in
place now this is being confirmed to be
partially set after the events of
Captain America Civil War so it will be
interesting to see how the back and
forth time jumps take place personally I
think Black Widow will be revealed to be
alive at the end after the events of
Avengers endgame and that'll be the
post-credits scene and yeah I'm really
interested to see how that goes down
they did actually show some footage of
the Black Widow movie and I'm gonna be
doing a video later today that kind of
breaks that all down so keep an eye out
for that and make sure you stayed locked
on the channel but for now yet really
excited to see what happens next was the
announcement that we officially getting
blade back
he's been cast as the guy who played
cottonmouth in Luke Cage so I don't know
how that's gonna work I guess they're
kind of pretending those shows never
happened but this is amazing amazing
news I've always been a massive fan of
blade maybe not blade Trinity but the
first two are absolutely stellar and he
has felt like a bit of a miss in the MCU
I've always when I went back and done
watch throughs of the Marvel movies I've
always started off at blade because I
feel like they are part of this and so
it's great that we're finally getting
him in some form or another they then
announced the first animated MCU series
called Marvel Studios what-if which will
feature
voices of people like samuel l.jackson
josh brolin Hayley Atwell karen gillan
jeremy renner yeah it's just gonna be
massive
it's if you've been following Marvel
Comics you obviously know that what ifs
are a big part of their universe and
they sort of show alternate events that
could have played out and the way things
could have happened differently and had
a huge effect on the world after this
though we didn't get an announcement of
the official day we did get confirmation
that the Fantastic Four movie is now in
development this is massive massive news
Marvel have wanted these characters for
decades and it's great that they finally
got them now and they're gonna start
with something big I'm really really
excited for the Fantastic Four I think
once you sort of bring Doctor Doom into
that you've just got an amazing billing
for the MCU going forward we didn't get
an x-men confirmation however we did get
Kevin Feige teased that mutants are
coming to the MCU which is you know
massive news I'm very very excited to
see how that goes down and that's pretty
much all of the updates though they
didn't get confirmed on the slate there
is rumors that black panther - Captain
Marvel - spider-man homeless guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 so yeah there's so
much to look forward to and I don't feel
like this panel had perhaps the big
hitters like The Avengers or the New
Avengers or the Dark Avengers or The
Young Avengers or any kind of Avengers
but there's so much here that's still
amazing and I really think Marvel are
going to knock it out of the park once
more now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this news has it's got you
excited for phase 4 or do you feel like
it was a bit of a disappointment just
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the marvel's avengers
leaked gameplay footage that i'll be
linked at the end in that video i'll
show clips of all the leaked gameplay so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to see what that game looks
like in action I'll leave that linked at
the end and hopefully I'll see you over
there after this also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of Avengers endgame to one lucky
winner and all you have to do is like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the face-full panel in the comment
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from there
whoever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace